Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Just a reminder before we get started, we love to hear from our listeners. You can email your comments and ideas to K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. Also, please consider rating us in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it. Some of us recall high school as being filled with fun parties, football games, and flirting,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。在开始之前提醒大家，我们非常乐意倾听听众的心声。您可以将意见和想法发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。此外，请考虑在 iTunes 上为我们评分，我们将不胜感激。我们有些人回忆起高中生活，觉得那是充满了有趣的派对、橄榄球比赛和调情，
while others think back to that time with a shudder and are just glad it's over. But is it really over? Does our social status as teens follow us for the rest of our lives? And can we raise today's children and teens differently in our ever-status-obsessed culture? Our guest for this episode is Dr. Mitch Princeton, a clinical child and adolescent psychologist, who is a John Van Cedars Distinguished Professor of Psychology and Neuroscience and the Director of Clinical Psychology at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill. Dr. Princeton wrote the book, Popular, Finding Happiness and Success in a World
而另一些人回想起那段时光时会不寒而栗，只庆幸它终于结束了。但它真的结束了吗？我们青少年时期的社会地位会伴随我们余生吗？在我们这个痴迷于地位的文化中，我们能以不同的方式抚养当今的儿童和青少年吗？本期节目的嘉宾是临床儿童与青少年心理学家米奇·普林斯顿博士，他是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的约翰·范·塞达斯心理学与神经科学杰出教授，也是临床心理学主任。普林斯顿博士撰写了《受欢迎：在一个过度关注错误关系的世界中寻找幸福与成功》一书。欢迎您，普林斯顿博士。谢谢邀请。我相信许多收听此播客的成年人可能正被传送回他们的青少年时代，回想起学校里那些酷小孩、不那么受欢迎的孩子，以及他们自己在那个社会等级制度中的位置。为什么思考“受欢迎”会瞬间把我们带回初中和高中的日子？是的，对某些人来说这可能是一场噩梦，因为我们确实回到了那里，对吧？我们仿佛记得走在走廊里是什么感觉，我们可能暗恋过谁，以及我们想变得像谁一样受欢迎。有些人试图忘记这一切。但现在有非常有趣的
that Cares Too Much About the Wrong Kinds of Relationships. Welcome, Dr. Princeton. Thanks for having me. I'm sure many adults listening to this podcast are probably being teleported back to their teenage years and are thinking about the cool kids in school, the not-so-popular kids, and where they themselves fit into that social hierarchy. Why does thinking about popularity instantly take us back to those days of middle school and high school? Yeah, it might be a nightmare for some people because we do go right back there, right? We kind of remember what it was like walking down the halls and who we might have had a crush on and who he wants to be as popular as. And some people kind of try and forget it all. But there's really interesting
心理学研究告诉我们，我们每天经历的任何事情、进行的任何互动、任何形式的社交机会，都会以某种方式通过我们的记忆进行过滤。而这些成年大脑构建的时期正是向青春期的过渡阶段。那时对我们来说最重要的事情是什么？是受欢迎程度。所以我们今天是在通过一个与我们高中受欢迎程度密切相关的过滤器或镜头来看待世界。接着你刚才说的话，我们许多人记得在初中和高中时渴望被接纳，但可能并不完全理解为什么会这样。在你的书中，你解释说这是因为青春期大脑发生的变化，使我们突然开始担心地位。
psych research now that tells us that every day as we experience anything, any interaction that we have, any kind of social opportunity, it somehow is all filtered through our memories. And the time when these adult brains were built is the transition to adolescence. What was the most important thing to us back then? It was popularity. So we are kind of viewing the world today through a filter or a lens that has a lot to do with our high school popularity. Going off of what you just said, many of us remember wanting to be accepted in middle school and high school, but maybe not understanding exactly why that was the case. And in your book, you explain that it's because of brain changes that happened during puberty that make us all of a sudden worried about status.
为什么会发生这种情况？我们并不完全知道原因，但有很好的进化理论告诉我们，过去当你长到12或13岁时，你需要开始准备独立生活并学习自主。所以大脑非常聪明地产生了一堆催产素和多巴胺的神经递质和受体。换句话说，当我们过渡到青春期时，我们对同伴之间的社交联系变得非常兴奋，当我们这样做时，感觉真的非常好。这种组合激励我们走出去，变得独立，并开始认为我们的父母变得完全过时了。今天，我们看到了同样的情况。所以就在你看到某人的身体出现青春期变化之前，你会注意到他们真的非常在意他们的社交关系是如何运作的。
Why does that happen? So we don't know exactly why, but there's good evolutionary theory that tells us that it used to be that when you turn 12 or 13, you need to start getting prepared to fend for yourself and learn autonomy. So the brain very cleverly kind of produces a bunch of neurotransmitters and receptors for oxytocin and for dopamine. So in other words, as we transition into adolescence, we become really excited about something. social bonding with peers, and it feels really, really good when we do. And that kind of combination inspired us to go out and be independent and start to think that our parents have become totally lame. Today, we kind of see the same thing. So just before you see changes in someone's body for puberty, you'll notice that they are really, really invested in how
那么，在这个年龄段，这些社交关系、友谊变得比亲子关系更重要，对吧？没错。那么为什么青少年时期的社会地位在成年后仍然重要呢？我的意思是，许多人会认为，那已经是很久以前的事了。13、14、15、16岁时的我并不是今天的我。为什么这很重要？嗯，那确实不是现在的我们，但我们内心深处可能仍然有一小部分存在，并且仍在影响着我们。
their social relationships are working. So is at this age where those social relationships, friendships, friendships become much more important than the relationship between a parent and child, right? That's right. And why does social status as teens matter when we're adults? I mean, many people would think that, you know, that was a long time ago. Who I was at 13, 14, 15, 16 is not who I am today. Why does it matter? Well, it's not who we are, but yet there's a little piece of us that might still be there, that still is influencing us.
这就是心理学家所说的社会信息处理，这实际上只是一个花哨的说法，意思是当我们观察环境时，我们注意到的东西，我们有成百上千的事情可以关注。而我们如何解读那些我们选择关注的事情，这一切都基于我们在青春期时的感受。所以如果你曾经是一个被拒绝的人，作为一个成年人，你现在可能会稍微多一点地看到拒绝，即使是几十年后。如果你是一个从未被拒绝、一直很受欢迎的人，你可能不擅长注意到暗示危险的信号，或者在你可能需要一些关键反馈的时候。我们看待世界的这些方式
It's what psychologists call social information processing, which is really just a fancy way of saying that what it is that we notice when we're looking out in the environment, we have hundreds and thousands of things we could be paying attention to. And how we interpret those things that we select to attend to, all of that is based on how we felt back in adolescence. So if you were somebody who is rejected, you might see rejection a little bit more now as an adult. even decades later. If you're someone that was never rejected, you were always popular, you might be bad at noticing signals that suggest danger or times when you might need some critical feedback. These kinds of ways in which we see the world
与我们青少年时期的人格密切相关。是的，你写道，受欢迎的青少年和儿童更有可能在成年后更快乐、更成功，并拥有更好的关系？嗯，这取决于情况。受欢迎的人可以分为两类。有些人在年轻时受欢迎，我们会称他们为“讨人喜欢”。
are very, very much related to who we were back when we were in our teenage years. Yeah, and you wrote how popular teens and children are more likely to be happier or more successful. and have better relationships as adults? Well, that depends. So those who are popular can be two different groups. You have some who are popular when they were young, and they would be the kind that we would call likable.
但青春期会出现另一种受欢迎。我们称那种受欢迎为“地位”。它们是截然不同的受欢迎类型。讨人喜欢是好的。地位则相当糟糕。你能多描述一下这两种受欢迎的含义吗？什么是地位，什么是讨人喜欢？当然。我的意思是，讨人喜欢是我们非常年轻时拥有的那种受欢迎程度。它曾经是你成年后重要的那种受欢迎程度。它基于
But then you have a different kind of popularity that emerges in adolescence. We call that type of popularity status. And those are very different types of popularity. Likeability is good. Status is pretty bad. Can you describe what those two types of popularity mean a bit more? What is status and what is likability? Sure. I mean, likeability is the kind of popularity that we have when we're really young. And it used to be the kind of popularity that was important as you were an adult. It's based
你让别人感到快乐、被重视和被包容的程度。这并不意味着你是一个软柿子，为了让每个人感觉更好而牺牲自己的需求。事实上，非常讨人喜欢的人很有可能成为领导者，但他们是以一种受欢迎和包容的方式做到这一点的。这并不是我们想到高中受欢迎程度时所想到的。我们想到的是“酷”是什么感觉。这在科学上确实转化为被所有人认识、引人注目、有影响力、占主导地位和强大。那种受欢迎程度被称为“地位”。而地位在长期来看有相当糟糕的结果，因为在高中对我们有效的方法在成人世界并不总是有效。是的。而且仅仅因为
on how much you make other people feel happy, valued, and included. And it doesn't mean that you're a pushover and you're making everyone feel better as opposed to fulfilling your own needs. In fact, highly likable people are very likely to become leaders, but they do it in a way that's welcoming and inclusive. That's not what we all think of when we think about what popularity was like in high school. We think about what it was like to be cool. And that really translates scientifically to being known by everyone, being visible, being influential, dominant and powerful. that kind of popularity is called status. And status has pretty bad long-term outcomes because what works for us in high school does not always work for us in the adult world. Yeah. And just because
某人拥有地位，你说是支配地位，并不一定意味着人们喜欢他们。没错。事实上，在高中，如果你还记得哪些孩子是最酷、地位最高的，研究表明至少有一半的孩子根本不喜欢他们。事实上，他们讨厌他们。但这并不意味着他们不认为他们很酷。同样的事情也发生在成年期。我们知道有些人拥有很高的地位。他们强大、占主导地位，甚至具有攻击性。我们可以承认这一点。但这并不意味着我们一定觉得他们让我们感到快乐、被重视或被包容。我们不喜欢他们。而且看起来当你处于那个年龄时，你更关心
someone has status, you said dominance, doesn't necessarily mean people like them. That's right. In fact, in high school, if you remember which kids were kind of the coolest that had the highest status, research says that at least half of the kids in school did not like them at all. In fact, they hated them. But that didn't mean that they didn't regard them as being cool, nevertheless. And the same thing happens in adulthood. We know that there are some people who have really high status. They are powerful and dominant and even aggressive. And we can acknowledge that. But that doesn't mean we necessarily find them to be making us happy, feeling valued or included. We don't like them. And it seems like when you're at that age, you are much more concerned about
那些确实拥有地位的人。而在成年后，我认为远离那样的人要容易得多。也许在工作场所不是这样，但在你生活的其他方面，似乎更容易忽略这一点。这是一个正确的评估吗，即在年轻时这样做更困难？是的，这完全说得通。部分原因是，我们认为大脑中的一些变化确实使我们与许多其他物种相似。许多哺乳动物物种对那种权力、支配地位和可见度感兴趣，因为这能让你获得更多的资源、食物或配偶，而我们的大脑表现得就像其他哺乳动物的大脑一样。
those people who do have that status. Whereas as adults, I think it's much easier to get away from people like that. Maybe not so much in the workplace, but in other aspects of your life, it just seems like it's easier to brush that off. Is that a correct assessment that's more difficult when you're younger to do that? Yeah, it makes perfect sense. And some of the reason why is because we think that some of these changes in the brain really make us similar to a lot of other species. A lot of mammalian species are interested in kind of that power and dominance and visibility. because it gets you access to more resources, food or mating partners, and our brains are acting like other mammals' brains.
即使是老鼠，当它们进入青春期时，它们对与成年老鼠交往的兴趣远不如与其他青春期老鼠交往的兴趣，因为它们对那种生物学上预设的获得地位的渴望非常感兴趣。所以在高中这样做很酷。那是我们可能会不可避免地感受到的东西，当我们的孩子进入青春期时，我们也应该预料到他们会有这种感觉。但过去我们会在高中毕业后停止
Even mice, when they reach their adolescent period, they're much less interested in hanging out with adult mice as they are other adolescent mice, because they're really interested in kind of that biologically programmed desire to have status. So that's cool to do in high school. that's something that, you know, we're probably inevitably going to feel, and we should expect our kids to feel that way when they reach adolescence. But it used to be that we would stop
关心那种受欢迎程度。然而，世界不再是那样运作的了。所以你是说人们，我们确实比某些人意识到的更关心它。我认为我们确实如此。事实上，我认为我们现在比我们物种历史上任何时候都更关心它，因为在过去20或30年里，情况发生了巨大的变化，使得我们现在比以往任何时候都更关心地位。这很可怕。你认为为什么会这样？关于原因有很多有趣的理论。你知道，有些人说这始于 CNN，信不信由你。那种24小时新闻周期是我们第一次不得不开始
caring about that kind of popularity when we graduated from high school. That's not the way the world works anymore, though. So you're saying people, we do care more about it, maybe than some people realize. I think we do. In fact, I think that we do now in this year than we ever did before in the history of our species because things have dramatically changed in the last 20 or 30 years in ways that now make us care about status more than we ever have before. That's scary. Why do you think that is the case? There's a lot of interesting theories about why. You know, some people say that it started with CNN, believe it or not. That kind of 24-hour news cycle was the first time that we had to start
改变我们谈论新闻的方式，我们让它更多地关注人和个人的经历。它突然改变了。我们对名人和地位的看法不仅限于极少数人。以一种不可及的方式，它突然变成了几乎任何人都可以拥有那一刻，那15分钟。一些理论认为，这是我们思考受欢迎程度方式发生变化的开始，这种变化在今天反映在社交媒体或真人秀等事物中，你知道，这是我们社会开始觉得我们都能分得一杯地位羹这一想法的延伸。过去并不是那样的。你认为这是否意味着今天青少年的生活比
changing the way that we talked about news, and we made it a little bit more focused on people and people's individual experiences. And it suddenly changed. Our view of celebrity and fame and status was not only afforded to a very few. In an inaccessible way, it suddenly became the case that almost anybody could have that moment, those 15 minutes. And some theories suggest that that was the beginning of a change in the way that we thought about popularity, a change that today is reflected in things like social media or reality TV, you know, extensions of the idea that our society started to feel that we could all get a piece of status. It didn't used to be that way. Do you think that translates to life being more challenging for teens today than it was
20、30、40年前更具挑战性？哦，我非常担心今天的青少年，因为他们生活在一个通过鼠标点击或在手机上24/7追求地位已经变得正常的世界里。当我写这本书时，我震惊地发现，无论是针对儿童还是成人的杂志封面，有多少都在宣传我们应该关心我们的点赞、转发和粉丝的信息。甚至孩子们也被鼓励在社交媒体上说出他们明确不相信的话，
2030, 40 years ago? Oh, I'm so worried about teens today because. because they've lived in a world where pursuing status with a mouse click or on your phone 24-7, that's become normal. And when I worked on the book, I was shocked to find how many covers of magazines for both kids and for adults are really promoting the message that we should care about our likes and our retweets and our followers. and even kids are being encouraged to say things on social media that they explicitly don't believe
因为如果这能给他们带来更多的点赞或粉丝，那就值得了。如果你想想这给孩子们传递的信息，即地位比与他人的真实联系或正直更重要，那是一个非常、非常可怕的信息。你在书的开头说，你希望它能作为一种方式，让人们重新审视
because if it gets them more likes or followers, then it's worth it. And if you think about the message that that's sending the kids, that status is more important than actual true connections with others or integrity, that's a really, really scary message. And you said it at the top of your book that you want it to serve as a way for people to reconsider
我们提到的文化，以及它对名声、受欢迎程度、名望、权力、财富和名人的关注，以及它实际上是如何让我们变得不快乐的。你能详细说明一下吗？嗯，研究已经观察了地位的影响。一些研究观察了那些现在地位最高的人。那些在我们社会中占据职位的人，可能是由于名声或在你的公司或政府中其他类型的地位职位。他们发现，那些处于最高地位的人患抑郁症的风险更大。他们也更有可能从事行为，特别是攻击性行为，只是为了维持或永远试图增加他们的地位。这有点像上瘾。一旦你有了地位或
our culture, as you've mentioned, and its focus on fame, popularity, fame, power, wealth, and celebrity, and how it's actually making us unhappy. Can you elaborate on that a bit more? Well, research has looked at the effects of status. Some research has looked at those who are the highest status now. The people who hold positions in our society, maybe due to celebrity or other kinds of positions of status in your company or in our government. And what they find is that those people who are in the highest positions of status are at greater risk for depression. They're also more likely to engage in behaviors, especially aggressive behaviors, just to maintain or forever attempt to increase their status. It's kind of an addiction. Once you have status or
一种地位，你就永远不会满足，无论你在社会等级制度中处于多高，你总是为了更多的地位指标而竞争。还有一些研究观察了高中那些酷孩子发生了什么，那些在地位方面最受欢迎的孩子。像弗吉尼亚大学乔·艾伦的研究，他追踪了那些酷孩子几十年。他发现，那些在青少年时期非常酷的孩子长大后患成瘾、焦虑、抑郁的风险更高，并且有关系问题。他们往往在关系中满意度较低，并且更频繁地被分手。所以这意味着那些受欢迎的儿童和青少年，可能是由于
one status, you can never have enough, no matter how high you are on the social hierarchy, you always are vying for more indicators of status. There's also been some research that's that's looked at what happened to those cool kids in high school, those kids that were the most popular in terms of status. Research like Joe Allen's research at University of Virginia, he's followed up those cool kids for decades. And what he's found is that those really cool kids as teenagers grow up to be at greater risk for addictions, anxiety, depression, and they have relationship problems. They tend to have lower satisfaction in relationships, and they're more frequently broken up with. So that means that children and teens who were popular, maybe due to
地位而不是讨人喜欢，但他们长大后却更有可能变得不受欢迎且不那么成功？没错。研究非常清楚地表明，讨人喜欢的孩子，即使是早在幼儿园年龄就讨人喜欢的孩子，他们拥有的好处可以持续几十年。他们赚更多的钱，更快乐，甚至更健康，寿命更长。他们在婚姻、工作和家庭关系中表现更好，甚至他们的孩子也表现得更好。所以讨人喜欢是非常强大的，这很有趣，因为我们没有花很多时间教导讨人喜欢，但结果表明我们应该这样做。地位的情况则相反。那些拥有高地位的人随着时间的推移长大后会有更糟糕的结果。我认为这通常反映在
status but not likeability, but then they grew up to be most more likely to be unpopular and less successful? That's right. The research shows pretty clearly the likable kids, even the kids that are likable as early as kindergarten age, they have benefits that last for decades. They make more money, they're happier, they're even healthier, and they live longer lives. They have better marriages and relationships at work and at home, and even their children do better. So likeability is extraordinarily powerful, which is interesting because we don't have spend a lot of time teaching likability, but results say we should. The opposite is the case for status. Those who have high status grow up to have worse outcomes over time. I think that's often reflected
你在谈论青少年长大后会发生什么时看到的一些电影中，我想到的是《等不及了》。如果你还记得那部电影的话。哦，有太多了。是的。那部电影浮现在脑海中，他们当时在做类似“明年”的事情。这就是那个受欢迎的运动员身上发生的事。他大学辍学了，在洗车店工作什么的，你知道，体重增加了50磅，无论是什么情况。
And some of the movies you see when you talk about what happens to the, you know, the teens when they grow up, I'm thinking of, can't hardly wait. If you remember that movie. Oh, there's so many. Yeah. That one's the one that comes to mind where they were doing like next year. This is what happened to the popular jock. He was like, dropped out of college and worked at a car wash or something, you know, and gained 50 pounds, whatever. Whatever the case was.
而那个书呆子类型的人，如果可以这么说的话，他赢得了女孩，去了某所大学。过上了很棒的生活。所以我们经常听到关于那些在青少年时期被拒绝的人，后来在成年后蓬勃发展的故事。那么一个人的受欢迎程度会随着时间而改变吗？绝对会。我们维持受欢迎程度的一些方式是，我们都陷入了一个始于高中的恶性循环。而我们大多数人并没有意识到我们现在正处于那个循环中。
And while the guy who was the nerd type, if you will, he got the girl and he went off to college somewhere. had a great life. So we often hear stories about people who were rejected as teens, who then flourish as adults. So can a person's popularity change over time? Absolutely. So some of the ways in which we maintain our popularity is we are all caught in a vicious cycle that started when we were in high school. And most of us don't realize that we're in that cycle right now.
它的运作方式是，我们在大脑对受欢迎程度最敏感的时候有这些重要的形成性经历，我们有伴随我们几十年的经历。无论我们是否公开思考它们，它们都在影响我们每天对每一次社交互动的反应方式。所以那些感到被拒绝的人可能不会去一个他们有机会建立新关系的派对，
And the way that it works is that we have these important formative experiences at the time when our brains are most sensitive to popularity, we have experiences that stick with us for decades. And whether we think about them overtly or not, they are influencing the way that we respond to every social interaction every single day. So people who felt rejected might not go to a party where they would have the opportunity to make new relationships,
或者他们可能会去那个派对，并假设人们不会喜欢他们。他们可能会双臂交叉，或者不进行眼神交流，或者在本来可以有主动权的时候不采取主动。在没有意识到的情况下，他们正在延续那种自我实现的预言，创造一个世界，为一个他们一次又一次被拒绝的世界做出贡献，以反映他们的期望，这些期望是在他们青春期时建立的。我们可以打破这一点的方法是认识到我们都有偏见，一种在
or they might go to that party and assume that people will not like them. They might have their arms folded or not make eye contact or not create an overture when there could have been one. And without realizing it, they are perpetuating that self-fulfilling prophecy of creating a world, contributing to a world where they get rejected again and again to mirror what their expectations were, expectations that were built when they were adolescents. What we can do to break that is recognize that we all have a bias, a bias that was
高中走廊里建立的偏见，它正在改变我们今天社交互动的方式。我们必须认识到我们的个人偏见是什么，并尝试挑战它，看看是否有可能认识到我们不再是15岁了，人们不会像过去那样对待我们。你的人生和你作为青少年时的样子正在影响你现在的生活，这绝对令人着迷。我的意思是，那是无意识发生的，我假设，对吧？这绝对是在内隐层面上的，但已经有非常有趣的研究来阐明这一点。有一项研究观察了有社交困难和没有社交困难的人。让他们看一部电影。
built in the halls of high school that's changing how we interact socially today. We have to recognize what our personal bias is and try and challenge it and see if there might be ways to recognize that we are not 15 anymore and people are not going to relate to us the way they did back then. That's absolutely fascinating that your life and who you were as a teen is affecting your life now. I mean, does that happen unconsciously, I'm assuming, right? It's definitely on an implicit level, but there's been really interesting research to shed some light on that. There was one study where they looked at people with and without kind of difficulties socially. And they had them watch a movie.
他们都看了完全相同的电影，但他们戴着特殊的眼动追踪眼镜。所以他们可以看到人们看了什么，以及他们看电影的那些部分看了多久。他们发现，过去有快乐社交生活的人看电影时，他们的眼睛真的专注于其他快乐的社交经历，人们微笑、点头和示意他人加入社交互动。但当有社交困难的人看同一部电影时，他们的眼睛花了近四分之三的时间盯着拒绝的线索，人们皱眉或看向别处或转动身体姿势。对我来说，这真的很令人震惊，我们在没有意识到的情况下，每天都在筛选
They all watched the exact same movie, but they wore special eye tracking glasses. So they could see what it is that people looked at and how long they looked at those parts of the movie. What they found was that people who had happy social lives in the past watched the movie and their eyes really focused on other happy social experiences, people smiling and nodding and gesturing for others to be included into social interactions. But when people with social difficulties watch the same exact movie, their eyes spent almost three quarters of the time staring at rejection cues, people that were frowning or looking away or turning their body posture away. And it really, to me, just is shocking how much without realizing it, we are screening
世界上的信息，这些信息证实了我们最坏的恐惧或最快乐的记忆。同样，这很大程度上与我们在12到15岁时首次构建这些成年大脑时所拥有的经历有关。你有什么关于如何挑战这些偏见的建议吗？我们可以做的一件事是，我们真的可以开始尝试获取新数据，尝试获取挑战我们期望的新体验。实际上有非常简单的方法可以做到这一点。有一种现象叫做社会模仿，它表明如果我们带着糟糕的眼神交流和双臂交叉走进一个房间，其他人会察觉到这一点。他们不会明白为什么，但他们会开始感到悲伤，并会立即对你做出假设，
out information in the world every day that confirms either our worst fears or our happiest memories. And again, a lot of that has to do with the experiences that we had when we first built these adult brains at the age of 12 to 15. Do you have any tips about how to challenge those biases? One thing we can do is we can really start to try and get new data, trying to get new experiences that challenge our expectations. And there are actually really simple ways to do that. There's a phenomenon called social mimicry that suggests that if we walk into a room with poor eye contact and with our arms folded, other people will pick up on that. They won't understand why, but they will start feeling sad and they will immediately make assumptions about you,
暗示你可能不是他们想要互动的人。有时我们从另一个角度思考。我们注意到一个让我们感到快乐并度过美好时光的人。我们有点说他们有正能量，或者你知道你喜欢和他们在一起，这会激发你最好的一面，这就是社会模仿。所以一个非常好的自我实验是，让某人进去并尝试一些不同的东西，尝试以比平时稍微好一点的心情走进去，或者和几个你通常不会打招呼的人打招呼，或者尝试微笑并保持双臂在身体两侧而不是交叉，人们会惊讶地发现他们能多快地打破这个循环，仅仅通过诱导
suggesting that maybe you are not someone that they want to interact with. Sometimes we think of it the other way. We notice someone that makes us feel happy and we have a good time. We kind of say something like they have positive energy or you know you enjoy spending time with them it brings out your best self that's social mimicry so a really good self-experiment is for someone to go in and try something different try to walk in in a little bit of a good mood maybe better than usual or say hello to a few more people you normally would or try and smile and keep your arms at your side rather than folded and people are surprised to see how quickly they can break the cycle just by eliciting you. from others a very different response to a social interaction. And once it happens one time,
来自他人的非常不同的社交互动反应。一旦发生了一次，
it starts to trigger more and more instances of where you can start changing those popularity dynamics in your life. And going back to teenage years, in your book, you identified five distinct groups that we all fall into during that time in our lives. And those were accepted, average, controversial, neglected, and rejected. Can you explain each one and what the benefits and concerns of each group are? Sure. Those are five different types of likability. And it's really based on the extent to which your peers select you as someone that they like the most or they like the least. It actually can be measured as young as the age of three years old and it's remarkably stable over time. The accepted kids tend to do really well. They're picked by
它就开始触发越来越多的实例，你可以开始改变你生活中的那些受欢迎程度动态。回到青少年时期，在你的书中，你确定了我们在生命中那个时期都会落入的五个不同群体。它们是：被接纳的、普通的、有争议的、被忽视的和被拒绝的。你能解释每一个群体以及每个群体的益处和担忧吗？当然。那是五种不同类型的讨人喜欢。它实际上基于你的同伴选择你为他们最喜欢或最不喜欢的人的程度。它实际上可以在三岁时就被测量出来，并且随着时间的推移非常稳定。被接纳的孩子往往表现得非常好。他们被
by others as being like the most, but rarely picked as like the least. And they tend to have lots of advantages and be more likely to become leaders. But the rejected kids have special powers also that's important. They're often picked as being like the least and not picked as like the most. But they tend to be particularly good at picking up on social cues suggesting rejection. And that could be very handy in a variety of different contexts. So don't rule out those who are rejected. Controversials tend to be picked as liked most. and liked least and might be especially likely to have high status and be status seekers in adolescence, whereas the neglected kids are not picked as liked most or liked least by their
其他人选为最喜欢的，但很少被选为最不喜欢的。他们往往有很多优势，更有可能成为领导者。但被拒绝的孩子也有重要的特殊能力。他们经常被选为最不喜欢的，而不被选为最喜欢的。但他们往往特别擅长捕捉暗示拒绝的社交线索。这在各种不同的背景下可能非常方便。所以不要排除那些被拒绝的人。有争议的人往往被选为最喜欢的
peers. And research initially thought that these might be kids who have trouble, but that's not true. They tend to be highly adaptable from context to context and very likely to change to become accepted over time. So if you are in these groups, is that just a group you belong to because of who you are, your personality, who you know, is it just something that's inherent to all of us, or are there ways to change this, to change which group we might belong to? We can absolutely change which group we belong to. One of the biggest predictors of how likable we are and which of those groups we fall in is the extent to which we act aggressively or in pro-social ways.
和最不喜欢的，并且可能特别有可能在青春期拥有高地位并成为地位追求者，而那些被忽视的孩子则没有被他们的同伴选为最喜欢或最不喜欢。研究最初认为这些可能是遇到困难的孩子，但事实并非如此。他们往往在不同背景下具有高度适应性，并且很有可能随着时间的推移改变成为被接纳的人。所以如果你在这些群体中，这只是因为你是谁、你的个性、你认识谁而属于的群体，它只是我们所有人固有的东西，还是有方法可以改变这一点，改变我们可能属于的群体？我们绝对可以改变我们属于的群体。我们有多讨人喜欢以及我们属于哪些群体的主要预测因素之一是我们表现出攻击性或亲社会行为的程度。
So aggressive kids are more likely to be controversial or rejected. And we tend to learn a lot about aggressive behavior by watching our parents or others. But we can also engage in pro-social behaviors, like paying attention to others, thinking about their needs, and engaging in behaviors that are welcoming and inclusive. Those are really powerful ways to make sure that we become accepted. The same rules that apply when we were on the playground in elementary school also apply in the workplace today or in one day our retirement communities. Those same dynamics play out in remarkably similar ways across the entire lifespan. And can you belong to more than one group at a time? Not typically, although there are some groups where it's easier to go between.
所以攻击性的孩子更有可能是有争议的或被拒绝的。我们倾向于通过观察我们的父母或其他人的攻击性行为来学习很多东西。但我们也可以参与亲社会行为，比如关注他人，思考他们的需求，并参与受欢迎和包容的行为。这些是确保我们变得被接纳的非常强大的方法。我们在小学操场上适用的规则也适用于今天的工作场所或未来的养老社区。同样的动态在整个生命周期中以非常相似的方式上演。而且你可以同时属于多个群体吗？通常不会，尽管有些群体之间更容易转换。
So neglected kids are not likely to suddenly become controversial. But we might see neglected folks become rejected or accepted based on how they start acting in a new environment. And when kids and teens get older, are there opportunities to change that? Like when they go to college, they're, you know, they're away from their home environment. they can kind of reinvent themselves be a new person. Is that an opportunity to maybe become a member of a different group that you weren't in when you were growing up? It absolutely is possible.
所以被忽视的孩子不太可能突然变得有争议。但我们可能会看到被忽视的人根据他们在新环境中开始表现的方式变得被拒绝或被接纳。当孩子和青少年长大后，有改变的机会吗？比如当他们上大学时，他们远离了家庭环境，他们可以重塑自己，成为一个新人。这是一个机会，可以改变成为你成长过程中没有加入的另一个群体的成员吗？这绝对是可能的。
It's not as easy as Freddie Prince Jr. movies would make you believe, but it is possible to change. The problem is, is that we don't talk very much about popularity or likability. So we don't teach people what behaviors they should engage in to change. There's research actually that shows that without any intervention, you can put a child into a brand new context, and within three hours, they have the same likable reputation that they had in their old context. So it's really important that we're talking about this and helping to teach kids why it's important to engage in likable behaviors. I'm sure there's certain approaches you want to take with that too, because you want to tell kids, you want to explain it,
这不像小弗雷迪·普林兹电影让你相信的那样容易，但改变是可能的。问题是，我们没有太多谈论受欢迎程度或讨人喜欢。所以我们没有教人们他们应该参与什么行为来改变。实际上有研究表明，在没有任何干预的情况下，你可以把一个孩子放到一个全新的环境中，在三个小时内，他们就拥有了他们在旧环境中拥有的同样的讨人喜欢的声誉。所以我们谈论这一点并帮助教导孩子们为什么参与讨人喜欢的行为很重要，这真的很重要。我相信你对此也有某些想要采取的方法，因为你想告诉孩子们，你想解释它，
I'm sure, in a healthy way saying like you want to get along with others, you want to be a part a group, you want to be, you know, liked in some ways without making them feel like they are sacrificing who they are to please others. How would you go about telling a child or a teen to how to do that? You're absolutely right. It's really important that kids know, just like adults, that we are going to be valued for being who we are. We just have to make sure that the way that we are is not somehow making other people feel inferior or dominated or somehow like they're not welcome as a member of the community. That's a really important message that unfortunately we've forgotten, perhaps now in this day, more than years past, where we live in a
我相信，以一种健康的方式说，你想与他人相处，你想成为一个群体的一部分，你想在某种程度上被喜欢，而不让他们觉得他们为了取悦他人而牺牲了自己。你会如何告诉孩子或青少年怎么做？你是绝对正确的。让孩子们知道，就像成年人一样，我们因为我们是谁而被重视，这真的很重要。我们只需要确保我们的方式不会以某种方式让其他人感到自卑或被支配，或者以某种方式让他们觉得他们不受欢迎作为社区的一员。这是一个非常重要的信息，不幸的是我们已经忘记了，也许现在在这个时代，比过去几年更多，我们生活在一个
society that's really about promoting our own voice rather than thinking of ways to help others feel connected and genuinely cared for as a community. And what advice do you have for parents of kids who are not popular, so they might fall into that neglected or rejected group? What can they do? I think it's really important for parents to think about how they can help their kids' social behaviors. But parents have to be realistic and honest about the ways in which their child might interact. First of all, I would say that I wouldn't want any parent to freak out if their kids were rejected, because there's a lot of research to suggest that having one or two very good friends can be really, really important and compensatory for folks who are having a tough time with rejection.
真正关于促进我们自己声音的社会，而不是思考帮助他人感到联系和作为社区被真诚关心的社会。对于那些不受欢迎的孩子的父母，他们可能属于被忽视或被拒绝的群体，你有什么建议？他们能做什么？我认为父母思考如何帮助孩子的社交行为真的很重要。但父母必须对孩子可能互动的方式保持现实和诚实。首先，我想说，我不希望任何父母在他们的孩子被拒绝时惊慌失措，因为有很多研究表明，拥有一个或两个非常好的朋友对于那些在拒绝中遇到困难的人来说可能非常、非常重要和具有补偿性。
So that might be the first goal is to really think about how to foster a couple of friendships. But if a child is experiencing difficulties with rejection, it's important to really look at whether that child might be acting aggressively or doing other things that make them not. respectful of the social norms. An example might be a kid who very pleasantly suggests an activity to play in, kind of let's all play Legos while everyone else is playing with cars. But instead of doing it in a way that seems to be respectful of what everyone else is already playing, they might do it in a very abrupt way that comes across as awkward and disruptive. That sometimes is the difficulty, and it is something that can be trained. And if you were that kid who was bullied or you were in that rejected group growing up during these crucial years. How can you find maybe some healing as adults?
所以这可能是第一个目标，真正思考如何培养几个友谊。但如果一个孩子正在经历拒绝的困难，真正观察那个孩子是否可能表现出攻击性或做其他让他们不尊重社会规范的事情就很重要。一个例子可能是，一个孩子非常愉快地建议一个活动来玩，比如“让我们都玩乐高”，而其他人都在玩汽车。但他们不是以一种似乎尊重其他人已经在玩什么的方式去做，他们可能会以一种非常突然的方式去做，这显得笨拙和具有破坏性。这有时就是困难所在，而且它是可以训练的。如果你是那个在这些关键岁月里被欺负或处于被拒绝群体中的孩子。作为成年人，你如何找到一些治愈方法？
Because we often hear about the long lasting impacts of being bullied or rejected because of whatever reason. So how can you yourself get over that experience and help to thrive as an adult? I wish that everybody knew about research on bullies that shows that in many cases it's bullying that is related to serious emotional difficulties. And it might be helpful for those who were victims to recognize that they were victimized not often because of their own weaknesses or any kind of difficulties that they may have experienced, but it really is more of a sign of how much bullies themselves were suffering from emotional distress where they were exposed to that kind of aggressive behavior somewhere in their
因为我们经常听到关于因为任何原因被欺负或拒绝的长期影响。那么你自己如何克服那种经历并帮助作为成年人茁壮成长？我希望每个人都知道关于欺凌者的研究，研究表明在许多情况下，欺凌与严重的情绪困难有关。对于那些受害者来说，认识到他们被欺负往往不是因为他们自己的弱点或他们可能经历过的任何困难，而是它实际上更多地是欺凌者自己遭受情绪困扰的迹象，他们在生活的某个地方暴露于那种攻击性行为，这可能会有所帮助。
lives, the more we can move away from making personal attributions from blaming ourselves from being a victim, I think the easier it would be to cope with and recognize that it was the bully that probably was experiencing a lot of difficulties. And the victim might have been the unfortunate recipients of that. But it doesn't mean that someone actually had any personal weaknesses that were worth being victimized about. And on the flip side of all of all this, so if for parents of kids who are really popular, either because of status or likeability, and this might be a two-part question, because those are very different aspects of being popular, what do those parents need to know? Well, I think that for parents of likable kids, that's terrific. And I think that that's a really good opportunity to really positively reinforce how kids are making others feel welcome and how they're being sensitive to other kids' feelings. So that might be something that parents want to really look out for and find opportunities to reinforce and help them generalize as they enter a world that values those behaviors, sadly, less and less.
我们越能远离做出个人归因，远离因为成为受害者而责怪自己，我认为应对它就越容易，并认识到是欺凌者可能正在经历很多困难。而受害者可能是不幸的接受者。但这并不意味着某人实际上有任何值得被欺负的个人弱点。而在所有这一切的另一面，所以对于那些非常受欢迎的孩子的父母，无论是由于地位还是讨人喜欢，这可能是一个两部分的问题，因为这些是受欢迎的不同方面，那些父母需要知道什么？嗯，我认为对于讨人喜欢的孩子的父母来说，那太棒了。我认为这是一个非常好的机会，可以真正积极地强化孩子们如何让其他人感到受欢迎，以及他们如何对其他孩子的感受保持敏感。所以这可能是父母想要真正留意并找到机会去强化和帮助他们概括的事情，因为他们进入了一个越来越不重视这些行为的世界，可悲的是。
But for kids who are high in status, it's going to be very, very hard to get kids to not be interested in status. I would recommend that parents remind those high status kids that it's important to be likable too. You can be cool and dominant and highly influential and visible, and you're not going to convince anyone not to be. But remind them that they should not maintain that by putting others down, by being aggressive, and being so overly focused on status that they're constantly seeking for more. Instead, teach them that while they might enjoy high status, they should also take time to let others feel included. Ultimately, it's not going to reduce their status, but it is going to help them develop the skills they'll need for decades to come. Can young people choose the type of popularity they want, especially today in this ranking culture,
但对于地位高的孩子，让孩子不关心地位将是非常、非常困难的。我建议父母提醒那些高地位的孩子，讨人喜欢也很重要。你可以很酷、占主导地位、非常有影响力和引人注目，你不会说服任何人不去这样做。但提醒他们，他们不应该通过贬低他人、通过攻击性以及过度关注地位以至于不断寻求更多来维持这一点。相反，教导他们，虽然他们可能享受高地位，但他们也应该花时间让其他人感到被包容。最终，这不会降低他们的地位，但它将帮助他们发展未来几十年所需的技能。年轻人可以选择他们想要的受欢迎程度类型吗，特别是在今天这个排名文化中，
with social media, being involved in every aspect of our teens' lives. And it seems like we can't go back from that. There's no putting the genie back in the bottle, if you will, and changing what teens are facing today in terms of the Internet and social media. Yeah, I think social media is here to stay. The platforms change often, but I think the teens have grown up not knowing anything but. And it's important that we acknowledge that there's something very reinforcing
社交媒体参与了我们青少年生活的方方面面。而且看起来我们无法回头。如果可以这么说的话，没有把精灵放回瓶子里，改变青少年今天在互联网和社交媒体方面所面临的情况。是的，我认为社交媒体将继续存在。平台经常变化，但我认为青少年长大后只知道这些。重要的是我们承认有一些非常强化的东西，
even biologically addictive about social media, that's going to be hard to change. So I suggest moderation. I think it's important that we allow teens to participate on social media. There's actually a lot of benefits that come from social media as well to adolescents. But we help them to also sometimes get off social media or use social media to promote actual face-to-face or voice-to-voice interactions as well, because there's still a place for that, and that's still important for child development. We can help teens think about how to use the direct message functions
甚至在生物学上对社交媒体上瘾，这将很难改变。所以我建议适度。我认为重要的是我们允许青少年参与社交媒体。社交媒体对青少年也有很多好处。但我们帮助他们有时也离开社交媒体，或者使用社交媒体来促进实际的面对面或语音对语音的互动，因为这仍然有一席之地，这对儿童发展仍然很重要。我们可以帮助青少年思考如何使用直接消息功能
or how to use the information they learn online to bring up in conversations offline. We also need to have parents talking a little bit more, according to research, about how kids are consuming the information they see on social media. Do they recognize that kids are liking one another's posts because they're fronting or because they are doing it to save face or maintain friendships, not because they necessarily agree with every value and behavior that's expressed in social media posts.
或者如何使用他们在网上学到的信息在离线对话中提出。根据研究，我们还需要让父母多谈谈孩子们如何消费他们在社交媒体上看到的信息。他们是否意识到孩子们点赞彼此的帖子是因为他们在装模作样，或者因为他们这样做是为了保全面子或维持友谊，而不是因为他们必然同意社交媒体帖子中表达的每一个价值观和行为。
I think digital media literacy is an untapped need within our school systems and among parent-child discussions that's really, really important in today's day and age. Can adults choose the type of popularity they want, you know, meaning, I mean, is status-in-harmes? or likeability. It seems like there's some push pull on that that you can work on. You mentioned a bit throughout the podcast. You can work on your likability skills. So adults, can they choose how to be the type of popularity they want? I think we are making those choices hundreds of times a day without realizing that. When we speak up in a meeting, when we decide what we're going to wear, when we decide what we're going to buy, when we decide what kind of interactions
我认为数字媒体素养是我们学校系统和亲子讨论中尚未被挖掘的需求，这在当今时代真的非常非常重要。成年人可以选择他们想要的受欢迎程度吗？我的意思是，地位是伤害性的吗？还是讨人喜欢？这之间似乎存在某种拉锯，你可以努力改善。你在播客中提到过一点，你可以提升自己讨人喜欢的技能。那么成年人可以决定他们想要哪种受欢迎程度吗？我认为我们每天都在不知不觉中做出数百次这样的选择。当我们会议上发言时，当我们决定穿什么时，当我们决定买什么时，当我们决定进行什么样的互动时，
we want to engage in or how much time we want to spend on our own social media feeds, we are making the choice. Are we trying to make ourselves stand out and seem somehow better than the rest of the crowd? Are we trying to garner more power and influence? Or are we making choices that signal to others that we care about them feeling valued, that we want others to feel included, and that we are more interested in creating connection and community than we are in making ourselves seem like we are better than others. I think we make hundreds of those choices a day.
我们想要参与其中，或者我们想在自己的社交媒体上花多少时间，我们都在做出选择。我们是在试图让自己脱颖而出，看起来比其他人更好吗？我们是在试图获得更多的权力和影响力吗？还是我们做出的选择向他人传达了我们关心他们的感受，我们希望他人感到被包容，并且我们对建立联系和社区的兴趣远大于让自己看起来比别人更好。我认为我们每天都在做数百个这样的选择。
And I hope that once people know about the two different types of popularity, it will give them some insight into how to make those choices wisely each day. And last question, I hope this is a fun one. What teen movie do you think best depicts everything we've discussed today? Oh, there's so many that I think are important. I think Never Been Kist is a great one. I think Breakfast Club is a great example of popularity in high school and the different groups that are out there. There's just so many, honestly, that I think are important.
我希望一旦人们了解了两种不同类型的受欢迎程度，就能让他们深入了解如何每天明智地做出这些选择。最后一个问题，希望这是一个有趣的问题。你认为哪部青少年电影最能体现我们今天讨论的所有内容？哦，我认为重要的电影太多了。我认为《一吻定江山》就很棒。我认为《早餐俱乐部》是高中受欢迎程度以及存在的不同群体的绝佳例子。老实说，我认为重要的电影实在太多了。
And it's interesting to me that a topic that we don't spend a whole lot of time investing policy dollars in or educational time in is the one way that we all, Hollywood and each of us, remembers. our adolescence. We can't think about our teenage years without thinking about popularity. And it's probably why we find those teen movies to be so important as a way of kind of working through what we all ubiquitously universally went through when we were teenagers. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Princeton. It's been a really wonderful conversation. Thank you. To learn more about the book Popular and other research from Dr. Princeton, visit Mitchprinstein.com. And before we go, as I mentioned, of the show. We'd love to hear from you. You can email me your comments and ideas to K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. We'd love to know
有趣的是，我们并没有投入太多政策资金或教育时间去研究的一个话题，却是好莱坞和我们每个人在回忆青春期时都会想到的。我们无法在不考虑受欢迎程度的情况下思考我们的青少年时期。这可能就是为什么我们觉得那些青少年电影如此重要，因为它们是我们处理每个人在青少年时期都普遍经历过的事情的一种方式。非常感谢您的加入，普林斯顿博士。这是一次非常精彩的谈话。谢谢。要了解更多关于《受欢迎》一书以及普林斯顿博士的其他研究，请访问 Mitchprinstein.com。在结束之前，正如我提到的，我们很乐意收到您的来信。您可以将您的评论和想法通过电子邮件发送给我，地址是 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们很想知道
what you think. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speaking of psychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您的想法。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，如讨论新心理学研究的《APA 期刊对话》和关于心理学实践的《进度记录》。您可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢娜。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。